what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back yes we're back to satisfy our
insatiable bloodlust for the lives of
superheroes and supervillains with
another installment of how to kill
superheroes so first things first I know
that I said at the end of my last video
that we were going to talk about how to
kill Chuck Norris but after having some
of my how to kill super superhero videos
demonetised because of YouTube's new
advertiser friendly policy and in light
of this policy where it's
family-friendly content and everything I
decided to doing a video on how to kill
a real person it simply would not be
worth the hassle because I've already
had to put up enough of a fight with the
how to kill superheroes as they exist
now I do not want to try to have to find
a way to justify a video on how to kill
Chuck Norris an actual real person so
we're not going to be able to cover that
until YouTube changes their policy and
basically advertisers realized but it's
2017 so anyway you're not guys we are
going to cover a hero or character you
guys have been asking for in the
comments for quite some time which is of
course Galactus that's right we're
finally going to figure out how we can
kill Galactus but before we do just like
always we're going to run over who
Galactus is and what his powers are so
Galactus actually started out as a
mortal man named Kalin who is an
explorer from the planet pas that
existed prior to the formation of the
moral universe as we know it well
actually its prior to the formation of
the Marvel Universe before Secret Wars
anyway it's all the same thing when that
universe came to an end Galland merged
with the sentience of his older universe
which is basically the existence of all
life in the universe itself and then
following this Gallants at dormant for
billions of years before he re-emerged
as Galactus a cosmic god-like being that
has to sustain himself by feeding on the
energy of entire planets and that's
pretty much what he does he chooses
individuals to be his Herald and sends
his underlings out into the universe
searching for planets for him to devour
now as far as powers go instead of
having a defined set of powers Galactus
is able to pretty much do anything he
wants and the reason for this is that he
possesses the power cosmic which is an
inexhaustible source of energy that
basically gives Galactus the power to
achieve any goal not a lot has been
explained about the power cosmic and
where it comes from
other than remarked by Silver Surfer
that it originated in the astral plane
but wherever it comes from it has
basically been used as a plot device to
give its bears a seemingly endless list
of abilities and so in addition to
possessing godlike levels of strength
speed and durability Galactus has also
displayed an impressive list of other
incredible powers throughout his history
now I would surmise the power cosmic is
probably fed by those individuals who
were just like but that doesn't make any
sense like that's probably where it gets
its source of energy from I have no idea
but furthermore Galactus is able to
manipulate matter on a molecular level
and he's caused the electrons in the
human torch's flames to contract
snuffing out his flames in the process
he's also turned Terrax into a worm and
then into pure energy so we can see one
of the reasons why Galactus is going to
be incredibly difficult to kill because
whatever comes at him he can basically
remove from existence in the blink of an
eye simply by scattering their molecules
throughout the universe No
in addition to all of this Galactus is
also a powerful telepath and telekinetic
even in a state of rest he's able to
resist the combined efforts of Charles
Xavier and Magneto who Charles is using
as a source of energy to bolster his
telepathic powers and after a telepathic
encounter with Galactus Thanos makes the
remark that collect his telepathic
abilities surpass any other beings he's
observed up to that point now with that
in mind we face the question of how to
kill Galactus how do we kill a being
that can withstand the combined forces
of some of Marvel's most popular and
powerful superheroes including the
Silver Surfer The Avengers and the
Fantastic Four well believe it or not we
have a couple of options first we can
use a device known as the ultimate
nullifier now if you're not familiar
with this the ultimate nullifier is one
of the most powerful objects in the
entire Marvel Universe and is one of the
only things that has been consistently
able to instill fear in Galactus in fact
an issue 5 of infinity war the madness
refers to the ultimate nullifier is the
most devastating weapon in the universe
we are going to finish infinity war I'm
going to answer that before you even ask
the question down in the comments now
what does this actually mean well
basically the person wielding the
nullifier can completely destroy whoever
or whatever they want including the
lactis as well as the entirety of the
universe itself
however there are a couple of obstacles
that make the ultimate nullifier a less
than ideal method of taking down
Galactus first of all using it requires
extreme concentration by its real dirt
if the person using it is not able to
concentrate completely the nullifier can
actually destroy them as well as
everything around them including the
universe so while the nullifier is
sufficient in power to take out Galactus
one latch and concentration and we run
the risk of blowing up ourselves as well
which wouldn't really do us any good so
even if we are focused enough to use the
nullifier successfully we have to first
be able to acquire it which is easier
said than done as the nullifier is
typically kept in Galactus workshop or
the Watchers base of operations and
Galactus is able to call the nullifier
to them at any point in time and so even
if we somehow get aboard Galactus a ship
or enter the Watchers Watchtower we run
the risk of Galactus simply calling a
nullifier to himself and leaving us
defenseless but if we decide that using
the nullifier is too risky we have
another option which we see play out
during the Galactus the Devourer
miniseries by Louise Simonson which I've
covered in depth here on my channel if
you want to go back and check it out so
to understand what happens in that story
we first have to understand Galactus
warship tattoo which he uses to aid him
in the consumption of planet by
penetrating the core of the planets that
he's targeting in order to consume their
energy so at the end of that miniseries
we find another method by which we can
eliminate Galactus and what happens is
that in order to stop Galactus from
consuming all life on Earth
Reed Richards invents a device that can
clog the siphoning machines on Galactus
ship and simply cause them to overload
and explode expelling all their energy
up to that point towards Galactus this
proves to be more than Galactus can
handle thereby killing him and turning
him into a star and so from these events
we can see that if we can expel enough
energy at Galactus he can be killed now
believe it or not we're still not done
as we stated before Galactus becomes
severely weakened when he goes extended
periods of time without consuming the
life force of planets and it's well
accepted that within the Marvel canon if
he goes long enough without feeding
Galactus can effectively starve to death
and so if we can take a lock us to a
place where there are no planets in
existence for him to feed on we can kill
him by starvation but does
place exists within the Marvel Universe
fortunately for us it does in the form
of the negative zone a dimension made up
entirely of antimatter in fact during
the events of Cataclysm The Ultimates
last stand
after the mainland Marvel Universe
version of Galactus merges with the
Ultimate Universe version he's managed
by the heroes of the Ultimate Universe
to the negative zone in hopes that he
would starve to death because Galactus
cannot feed on antimatter
and finally we come to perhaps the
simplest way to kill Galactus which is
to capitalize on his insatiable hunger
and poison a planet he intends to
consume this has actually happened
before when the son of the Incredible
Hulk hero kala poisons Galactus with a
combination of the power cosmic and the
old power which is basically an unstable
source of energy that was created when a
group known as the Shadow Priests tried
to recreate the power cosmic
now while Galactus did survive the
poisoning it did nearly killed him and
hero Carla tells Galactus that if he
consumes a planet containing the old
power again he will die so in order to
kill Galan chest seemingly all we would
have to do is inject the old power into
a planet the Galactus is about to
consume so there you have it round court
I think we came up with some pretty
solid ways to kill Galactus he's a lot
easier to kill than we thought he would
be right like for an I omnipotent force
that Stanley claims is the most powerful
being in existence which Stanley should
be trusted Stanley's a guy that helped
to pioneer Marvel Comics I don't really
know why we wouldn't trust Stanley
Stanley I Love You Man no we will not do
a video on how to kill Stanley it would
be just our luck that we would make that
video and then Stanley would
unfortunately pass away so by the way I
hope you guys got signatures from
Stanley for all your comments and stuff
because he has stated that he's not
doing any more coming book tours on the
East Coast he's only sticking to the
west coast get them while you can
because soon he will not be going to any
cons just want to throw that out there I
got a signature from Stanley but I hope
you guys oh you guys got yours anyway
yeah we have basically killed the
likeness which is kind of cool the
problem is that now we have unleashed
Abraxas a multiversal entity who's
literally the living embodiment of
destruction and in Marvel Comics 1 on a
crusade that resulted in killing every
single version of Galactus in existence
across the multiverse oh good job
Rockport good job guys you've basically
just destroyed the multiverse you've led
to our complete and total destruction
all across the multiverse I blame you
for what happens next but
you're near your to come let's explain
make sure you hit the side button to
become part of the rob course you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will get you a letter
peace
[Music]